in 2017 Amazon brought in 177 point
eight six billion dollars in revenue and
employs over 500,000 people it has
boosted its creator Jeff Bezos to be the
richest man alive and allows him to make
several billion dollars each month and
thus building a huge lead over Bill
Gates overall Amazon has evolved so much
that it is quite undoubtedly the number
one online retailer for pretty much
everything but how exactly the Amazon
get here and where did this company
originate but before we discuss that
make sure to hit the subscribe button if
you guys would like to see more of
origin stories just like this one and
post down in the comments below what
company you guys would like me to cover
next so starting off Jeff Bezos started
Amazon or Cadabra Inc which was its
original name on July 5th 1994 Jeff
actually made a huge gamble when he
decided to do this he was actually the
vice president of de shortcode but he
strongly believed that the internet was
the future and he really did not want to
miss out on any great opportunities well
he was definitely right Jeff actually
considered changing the name of the
business - relentless comma but decided
otherwise fun fact if you guys type in
relentless calm right now it'll still
take you to amazon.com originally he had
ambitions to make Amazon the biggest
book store in the world like the Amazon
River the biggest river in the world
Josh discovered that the internet was
projected to grow in web Commerce by
2300 percent and as a result he created
a list of 20 items that he could sell
online like compact discs computer
hardware computer software videos and of
course books eventually he decided to
focus on cranium bookstore because of
the worldwide demand for books and the
low price point of them along with a
vast selection he started at Amazon and
as a garage in Bellevue Washington in
just the first two months of business
Amazon was able to sell it to all 50
states and
to over 45 countries and her sales were
up to $20,000 a week in October 1995
Amazon announced that it was officially
public in 1996 Amazon was reincorporated
into Delaware at Amazon issued its
initial public offering of stock on May
15 1997 however everything was going
good for Amazon Barnes & Noble actually
sued Amazon on May 12 1997 because
Amazon claimed themselves to be the
world's largest bookstore but according
to Barnes and Noble this was completely
false because Amazon wasn't even a
bookstore in the first place the Barnes
& Noble a bazaar was simply a book
broker
fortunately the suit was dealt with an
Amazon continue to make the same claim
but it wasn't over for Amazon yet in
1998 Walmart suit Amazon because
supposedly Amazon was stealing Walmart's
insider secrets by hiring former Walmart
executives
however this too was settled out into
the court if you guys were will ever
wondering where the arrow under Amazon
came from and that arrow has actually
been implemented into the logo for a
very long time now
if you pay close attention then you
notice that the arrow connects the a and
a Z in the word Amazon and this
represents the Amazon carries everything
from A to Z despite these great sales
and booming growth Amazon has still not
become profitable and investors were
starting to have second thoughts about
their decisions however Amazon kept
growing survived the dot-com bubble and
finally turned over a profit in the
fourth quarter of 2001 however the
profits were still very miniscule
compared to their sales Vinod I had to
revenue exceeding 1 billion dollars but
the final profit was only 5 million
dollars or 1 a 1 cent per share however
it did establish that Amazon could be
successful even if it is a slow climb
Jeff was also very intent on not
limiting Amazon to just be a retailer
but also a technology
in 2002 Amazon launched AWS or Amazon
Web Services which provided users with
internet traffic patterns website
popularity and other statistics for
developers and marketers in 2006 Absa
implemented Elastic Compute cloud or ec2
into AWS which rent out computer
processing power in various increments
later that same year simple storage
service or s3 also came out which rest
data storage over the Internet similar
to Google Drive or onedrive as three and
easy to remove Astley successful and
excel at seven
the s3 service housed over 10 billion
items five years later it contained over
905 billion items even some competitors
of Amazon like Netflix take advantage of
the s3 and ec2 for the respective
services
additionally in 2006 Amazon began their
fulfillment by Amazon program that
highly increased variety and their
inventory and left a much faster growth
furthermore in 2007 Anzac came out with
a Kindle e-reader which made electronic
reading much more popular in 2011 Amazon
came out with the Kindle Fire and by
2012 like Kindle Fire constituted for
about 50% of the Talbots sold that used
Google's Android mobile operating
systems in 2011 Amazon only had 30,000
employees in just five years they grew
to 180,000 employees on top of this they
were experimenting in this part speaker
market as well Amazon first brought out
the echo in 2014 and while many people
questioned this technology and didn't
believe in its future the smart speaker
did really well and led to many new
versions and has even led to other
companies bringing out their own smarts
makers like Apple slowly
Amazon also began to invest deeply in
India for example they announced a two
billion dollar investment in India 2014
and just two years later they've poured
another three billion dollars into India
likewise happens are also invested into
many companies one of the most durable
companies is Whole Foods which they
bought just last year for staggering
13.7 billion dollars as mobile devices
and online shopping became more popular
everyone has just shot up mind-boggling
amounts and Amazon stuff has a very
bright and hopeful future because many
parts of the world are still exposed to
such services and tusk can't take
advantage of them but that's how ABS
I've got to where they are now so what
do you guys think is next for Amazon
whatever czar continue this exponential
growth well Jeff Bezos become the first
trader make sure to post your produces
down below and suggest what company you
guys would like to see next
on this channel also if you enjoyed this
then make sure to hit the like button
and subscribe to see more videos just
like this one but until next time
[Music]